If you've ever dabbled
with web development,
then you'll be familiar with
the box model in CSS layouts.
If you haven't, let's take a quick tour.
Now all UI elements in Android
take up a rectangular space
equal to the minimum rectangle
needed to enclose the object.
We call this the content bounds.
Take this avatar place holder image for
example.
Even though the image is a circle.
It's content bounds are this
enclosing rectangle.
Well, that's not entirely accurate.
The objects bounds also include
any padding, that is, any space
that is considered to be part of the
object that push its bounds outwards.
So, in our example, the bounds would
be equal to the content's area and
plus any padding applied to it.
When positioning an element
relative to other elements,
you might also want to leave
some space between them.
This is where we can use margins to
add extra space between objects that
critically isn't considered
to be part of the element.
So we've seen how both padding and
margins can be used to add
extra space around an element.
So you might be wondering when
to use one or the other or
perhaps even a combination of both.
Now the key thing to remember is that
if you want the space to be part of
the object, then you should use padding.
And if you don't want it to be part of
the object, then you should use margin.
So, when do you want it to be part
of the object becomes the question.
The answer is if you want the touchable
area or the background of the object
to be enlarged, then use padding,
otherwise use margin.
So in our example, if you want this
avatar to be clickable with a nice,
big touch target.
But we don't want any touch highlight to
extend too far towards the other items.
We could use a combination of padding
around the element to enlarge
the touch area.
And then margin between the elements
to separate them out without that being
part of the clickable zone.
For those familiar
with the web box model,
notice that there's no
concept of borders.
While you can still apply borders,
these are typically achieved
using background images.